[MUSIC]
[NOISE]
Hello, today you are joining to me on a
field trip to Russia.
Three centuries ago, Russian czar Peter the
Great
decided to establish the Russian Academy of
Sciences.
The only problem was: there were no
scientists in Russia at that time.
It didn't stop the czar, and he traveled
throughout Europe,
trying to convince leading European
scientists to relocate to Russia.
He did not succeed, since Russia was
considered an unpredictable and even
dangerous country at that time.
However, Johan Bernoulli, the leading
European mathematician, passed the invitation
to his student Leonhard Euler
[INAUDIBLE].
And in 1727, the 20-years-old Euler
arrived to
[INAUDIBLE]
cold Saint Petersburg, and he eventually became
one of
the world's greatest mathematicians.
In 1735,
Euler solved
the famous "Seven Bridges of Konigsberg" Problem.
The city of Konigsberg, in the kingdom of
Prussia, was built on two sides of the
river
Pregel,
and consisted of two islands that were
connected
by seven bridges with each other and with
the mainland.
The problem was to find a walk through the
city that would cross
every bridge exactly once and return back.
Euler not only solved this problem for the small
city of Konigsberg with just seven
bridges,
he developed a universal idea on how
to solve such problems for imaginary
cities with millions of islands
[INAUDIBLE]
and millions of bridges.
We are in Konigsberg.
This is the one of the bridges,
[INAUDIBLE].
this is one of the islands,
this is another island,
and this is the Pregel river.
[INAUDIBLE].
And our goal today is to find a walk
[INAUDIBLE]
through the city that would visit every
bridge exactly once.
There are many strategies to explore -
- let's go - I'll meet you at the next bridge.
Wait a second -
what do seven bridges of Konigsberg
have to do with bioinformatics?
It may come as a surprise, but without Euler,
[INAUDIBLE],
we probably wouldn't be able to assemble
genomes today!
We can think about your genome as a giant
3 billion nulceotide-long text.
Four decades ago,
biologists figure out how to read genomes,
but, they still don't have technology that
would be able to
read the genome the same way we read a book,
from the first nucleotide till the last nucleotide.
What they can do though, is to read
short snippets of the genome called reads,
[INAUDIBLE],
which may be very short, like 200
or 300 nucleotides.
The problem, however, is that biologists
do not know from
what region of the genome each snippet, or
DNA read, came from.
And as a result, they have to figure out
how to assemble them together.
To do this, they generate millions of
overlapping reads
[INAUDIBLE]
and use these overlaps
To figure out how the reads
[INAUDIBLE]
follow each other in the genome.
[INAUDIBLE].
Essentially, it is a giant
[INAUDIBLE]
overlap puzzle.
[INAUDIBLE].
Again, what does it have to do with the Seven
Bridges of Konigsberg?
[INAUDIBLE]?
Today, we will learn how to build a
city with
millions of islands and millions
of bridges in such a way
that every bridge corresponds to a DNA read.
And after we learn how to walk in
this megacity, you will be able to
assemble genomes.
I'll meet you at the next bridge, after
we are done.